[Music]
excuse me what
oh he's hanging out with the realest
people yeah
uh he went to the gathering of the
juggalos i knew it because i saw all the
way to the right the chick yeah and i
was like this has to be juggler related
whoa whoa whoop
it's been seven years since i watched
this youtuber joe goes head of the
gathering of the juggalos the gathering
was cancelled last year because the
pandemic but it's back in action this
year so i went to the middle of nowhere
in ohio to see the insane clown posse
themselves along with vanilla ice kid
and play stevo and even chris hanson
that sounds like hell frankly that
sounds like hell
i don't know
was he kidding play
you didn't take any bad checks from
chris hanson did you catch a predator
come check out the wildness
[Music]
you haven't thought of the smell
wait they have to put the porta potties
that close to the stage oh [ __ ] bro so
you could jam out
[Music]
yes i'm at the goddamn gathering i love
it man i feel like i'm walking on
sunshine i love that dude are you on
youtube or something yeah you want me to
follow you yeah yeah you know that's
just not real it's all social media [ __ ]
nobody gives a [ __ ] about you in real
life
that that escalated very quickly [ __ ]
for no reason
anybody in your family but on your
online [ __ ] who really gives a [ __ ]
social media is not real no the only
people that really lie man
the people that are here with you and
the people that support you and the
people that are here which busy brother
is this i don't know
that it might just be gary that might
actually be honest it's just me gary
maybe it's jake
jake [ __ ] money in your pocket as
you're putting money in there's your
goddamn helping them out they're helping
you out in real life not [ __ ]
over facebook instagram all that
[ __ ] i feel you all that followers
all that follower [ __ ] i know you got
your youtube channel and that's what's
up man oh hell yeah what's your name bro
be thank crazy p
what's what
this guy an aw wrestler
no his makeup's too good
oh that's never heard of him he's not
going to fight with darby alex
i thought that was darby allen i'm going
to come out with darby allen
i am here for the family
pete thing how you feeling today man i'm
gathering i am here with my fam it's
been two three years for me saw the
little videos of our homes we're killing
it we are getting raw and god damn it
we're getting naughty you can bleep that
out since it's youtube but hey
screw it watch me
and i'll tell you another thing
so this guy's 20 kick me the nuts that's
not bad
drop me i'll give you 50 back wow that's
a lot of confidence in your nut strength
dude
i'm impressed [ __ ] it 100 bag if you can
make your best change i'll give you a
hundred dollars wow you don't have a
coupon or anything that's what's great
about america is the entrepreneurship
you know mm-hmm
the entrepreneurial spirit if you have a
dream you could do it
did you ever have a dream where you
could where you that guy all grown up
and
nuts do you think he's gonna go down
i don't think he's gonna go down if the
man has the balls to do it can i say
you know i'd heard some bad stories but
terry funk looks really good
jesus christ
he looks fantastic
are you sure i'm positive you're 100
no
i think he's gonna go down to it ready
for the whole down that's pretty good
logic right right who's got 20 bucks to
kick this dude in the nuts what's up bro
how are you feeling pretty good right
now actually it's just like a wow wow
wow
she's doing nitrous he's doing whippets
okay yeah oh wow wow
this is camp camp we've been here for
four years
at this location in the spot
my thoughts
creative bro camp camp we just party
hang out we provide everybody with party
favors if they need it you didn't hear
that from me so you could have helped me
out with the family sell drugs why would
you say that so you sell drugs why would
you say that not only did you announce
that you sell drugs but you also
announced pretty much what your tour
dates are gonna be
you see that right
and just chill listen to the music not a
great playlist this year but you know
what [ __ ] it we're just chilling hanging
with the family it's all it's like a
pure utopia here it's hard to explain
how it is here you just have to be here
to experience it yo yo he wants to do it
what's your name chris
oh he's gonna somebody actually paid him
to kick him in the balls
wow
stone face how does he do the face i
don't know what if he doesn't have a
what if it's a trans woman or that's a
dude that's a [ __ ] it's a trans dude
yeah
because that would be a great gimmick oh
stone face
my name's sable it's lovely to meet you
all
frozen that's not stable frozen i think
she looks terrible i think she's single
now are we sure sable's not part of the
aw roster
frozen what do you think
nope no hold on a second maybe she's a
good personality yeah you don't know
yeah juggalo
my name's sable lovely to meet you all
david nice to meet you your name my
name's luke i like that
i guess she was interested in someone
else weird accent from her
yeah that's not a real problem
london darling you got a cigarette it's
not from fancy oh of course i can't be
smoking like a peasant why don't you
tell any of the fellas watching what
they need to do
juggle a woman like yourself oh you must
understand that a woman's body is her
own
oh this is scary spice right
yeah dude remember yeah scary spice was
hot that's actually kind of mean
she shares it openly in the wide world
to please herself and no one else you
hear a whoop whoop in her heart don't be
afraid actually with those teeth i'm
starting to think maybe she's not maybe
that accident's not so fast no i think
she might actually be british she's
straight out of the big book of british
smiles
let her ride you like a steed through
the english countryside don't be an
imbecile or a trump supporter these
things oh be vaccinated you could get
some pretty okay i'm not gonna have
anybody at a [ __ ] juggalo convention
tell me to get vaccinated right first of
all you look like you look like a
[ __ ] dump truck with a busted grill
you look like a dump truck with front
end damage it's really mean and you're
gonna [ __ ] tell me you're gonna give
me a list of demands apparently
see amazing blow jobs from fat girls you
know we're not made for hugging and
cooking and loving for no reason you
know i mean how you getting naughty p
thing this guy i think might be my
favorite who pee thing yeah pee things
probably that's pretty cool
and i get down excuse me what
right right yeah
fellas tell the people who you are
excuse me what no not just kidding no no
we're open-minded we're open-minded
gorilla pimp with rogue scout are they a
group
maybe larry
is open-minded on aw dark frozen are
they but they're going up against the
dark orders yeah is that who they are
they're going out there they're they're
fighting uh
daniel garcia and 2.0 stop with daniel
garcia you [ __ ]
gallery and open-minded at the
[ __ ] gathering with excuse me
what excuse me what excuse me what so
we're all hardcore performers we've been
playing stages all [ __ ] weekend we're
going to keep doing it we've been
[ __ ] hard to pay to be here we got
these baller sites we're repping this
acting for the juggalos especially in
the midwest south dakota minnesota iowa
nebraska what up [ __ ] whoops
whoa whoa excuse me what excuse me what
what i apologize
2.0 they're facing uh
the wingmen
i hate that you're not even kidding
you know like i hate that that's serious
open-minded is a hardcore band
from minnesota
well i don't i've never heard of them
they're on tour right now with rather
rory the rugged man who he's a rapper
is he a white rapper
he's a white rapper isn't he
he's
white
in the yes gallery what excuse me what
what's up with the faygo thing it's
[ __ ] sweet deliciousness how i like
to shower pour it on your toothbrush
remember when we went to the uh the very
first year of the show we went to the
gathering of the juggalos over in dc or
with the protesting they did we showed
up with a couple bottles of fago that we
got from one of the gas stations and
they treated the sheets we'd go way off
[ __ ] i-4 to go get it but they
treated us like royalty
oh yeah that's why i made because i that
was i was like dude we have to make sure
we get faygo
and uh we had to go quite out of the way
for it but it was actually worth it
because yeah they totally were like
these guys these guys are cool they got
cotton candy fago brush and brush your
teeth with it the wet t-shirt contest is
it water or faygo it's manny fago mainly
vegan a lot of dildos and microphones in
the ass too so all right make sure you
zoom in real close
tell us what you're doing here man so um
we're here as a jesus loves juggalo
what
what is
what is jesus saves juggalos
it's pretty self-explanatory dude it's a
christian arm of the jugular
organization
preach and we're out here just showing
the love of jesus to the juggalos so do
you show the love of jesus at like a
bunch of different events or is it
always like juggalo focus the juggalo is
the one singular focus that i do and we
come down from florida every year
why
how did you come up with the idea to
intersect jesus [ __ ]
what i'm giving you the sight
is did jesus a juggalo site is it good
oh it is good is it good
juggalo outreach
let's see here
what is a juggalo juggalo outreach oh
yeah that's what they have the about
okay but you're all right so
juggalos
oh my god look at the logo did you see
the logo yes it's a juggalo but instead
of like a hatchet
all right look
isn't all right so it's a group of
psycho clowns it's psychopathic records
right it's
hatchets and demons and bloody murders
and like
gore music basically yes not a good
target demo
i don't know like you i don't know you'd
be [ __ ] surprised man honestly
most of the people are there to do drugs
and fornicate
yeah go i think going to any concert to
preach is probably a bad time and a
place
jesus christ
oh let's go back though because i want
to
here it is
and juggalo so at the age of twelve i
started doing drugs and i got heavy
drugs that's when i first heard the icp
music as well was when i was 12 years
old and i became a juggalo so i was a
part of the culture i didn't know do you
think that maybe those things are
are connected
do you think maybe the juggalo thing and
the drug thing are connected
jesus was got saved in 2007 in a jail
i'd been getting arrested for doing
drugs and drinking and driving i was
sitting in jail and i uh met jesus in a
true way i'd been jailed church as a kid
but i had never truly experienced a
relationship with jesus so then i got
saved and i kind of yeah the rest of
jesus are [ __ ] with that bank
remember that's that'll get you in
trouble i'm doing the drugs i stopped
listening to the music and in 2012 i
felt like god said hey it's now time to
go back and he told me i needed to come
back and share this love with the
juggalos so god actually told you get
back into the juggalo community yes sir
i was like hey i want nothing to do with
that i had went around some old friends
and they were still doing the same stuff
smoking the same things sitting on the
same couch and
look man good for you i'm glad he got
his life turned around but you're
honestly preaching to juggalos let's go
back to the hospital i won the hottie
mine comes true what was your wish i
can't tell you but you might know next
year
i you know what i i don't like that
she's hitting on him again yes and i
don't like the fact that this giant pig
woman
with bad teeth
has been leaning on that accent as a
crotch for so long
like that's all she's got that's her
thing and she really milks that accent
that's right of course darling good with
those [ __ ]
hideous teeth
oh okay come to my camp me and my love
and my family have edibles
come enjoy yourself thank you she wants
to [ __ ] him
so hard every juggalo chick just wants
to [ __ ] everybody
no i know i know but he does he does
pretty well though you know yeah i know
he does well but this isn't exactly his
finest moment as far as uh attracting a
mate he's attracted some women before
i'm like damn good for homie like
remember that the hispanic or the
girl the one that was like well i wasn't
hitting on you oh yeah that was
the one that was hitting on him until
she wasn't i tell you guys i have a
girlfriend
on you anyway yeah whatever and then
just walked away all pissed like okay
yeah all right i appreciate the offer
how you feeling dude i'm feeling pretty
[ __ ] good day two you're looking good
pressure were you wearing this yesterday
well i had a little different color
g-string on but pretty much yeah
yeah i had the crown royal peach one on
yesterday
just making sure that that's not me
[Laughter]
just double check guys better hair okay
that's not me i'm almost sure that's not
me
pretty much yeah trust this dude does
not wear deodorant [ __ ] dicks yeah
you don't know what's about to say this
isn't a costume i woke up like this bro
this is how she happened to dress today
this is an everyday thing no well this
juggalo [ __ ] is an everyday thing that's
a fact i mean maybe sometimes it's
sweatpants and [ __ ] you know whatever
else but it's it's an everyday [ __ ]
thing i have a feeling a lot of days
it's sweatpants i have a feeling these
people are still living off stimulus
jokes
i have a very strong feeling i have a
feeling that uh they've been living on
stimulus checks since before covert
oh no absolutely i mean nothing to do
with how you dress although i will say
if you're a juggler you can pick a
juggle out in the crowd like that how do
you notice them what do you notice what
do you mean how this smells like braids
sometimes that's a dead giveaway yeah
okay um so i i'm gonna give you a heads
up sir also non-juggalos can spot a
juggalo in a room anywhere
[ __ ] ride the [ __ ] hey
stockwell
i've been making music no [ __ ] like
16 17 years he's been down like the
whole [ __ ] they've all been here
been since been since oh gee like here
we go okay you have to understand what's
crazy about all of this to me because
there's a lot of festivals like my
father went to woodstock there's been
this kind of [ __ ] isn't new but don't
compare there is no other scene like
this one
this is what it is
woodstock
okay jimi hendrix played
oh jimi hendrix you're so cool
cool
sure royce this is just like bonnaroo
show me
let me ask you something if jimi hendrix
is so cool how come he never headlined a
gathering of the juggalos because he
died cooler than this
yes
us jugglers can take anybody so [ __ ] you
if you disagree with me
what happened
like five six years ago but i i i
actually on day wave a couple years ago
found him
he still has a youtube channel he's like
an adult now still a juggalo still
making music good for him still making
music still killing it still doesn't
have a battery and a smoke detector good
friend like he is just [ __ ] crushing
it oh he starts
peep